[Music]
before you see the latest CGI kids movie
that adults will probably get more out
of revisit the Disney hit that made you
laugh cry won an Oscar and best of all
isn't frozen big hero six prepare for a
movie based on a Marvel comic you had no
idea existed that Disney removed all the
Marvel branding from and didn't tie in
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe despite
the fact that it has a team of quippy
heroes going up against a forgettable
villain with a vague plan in a final
battle with the sky based doomsday
device made of disposable robots and and
after credits seen with Stanley I mean
come on this is the marvelous non Marvel
movie ever journey to a way less foggy
slightly more Asian version of San
Francisco and meet baymax an adorable
combination of WebMD and a marshmallow
he's the inflatable Robo nurse everyone
wants to cuddle with until you realize
he's voiced by the depressed middle-aged
comedy writer from 30 rock who watch
baymax came up with a super orphan hero
hero hero hero hero hero hero is a hero
burrito hero hero hero
hero Kira my name is Kira whatever he's
a protagonist with the hair of a
Japanese anime and the tooth gap of
every kid from recent Western animation
thrill as this miniature version of Tony
store makes inventions that will put
everyone on earth out of a job what used
to take teams of people months or years
and now be accomplished by one person
and immediately transforms his inherited
healthcare robot into a killing machine
I fail to see how karate makes me a
better healthcare companion
punch this it's like Terminator 2 but in
Reverse after the sci-fi pessimism of
wall-e experience a kid's bill that's so
into science it turns it into magic
justified by the tiniest bit of
scientific mumbo-jumbo whoa Hydra mag
suspension magnetic bearing servos
laser-induced plasma metal embrittlement
yeah um
Wingardium Leviosa and watch as these
scrappy college kids create
billion-dollar inventions and get
rewarded with dinner dinner is fun
nothing is better than free food just
like the NCAA experienced a moving film
about the power of friendship
forgiveness and innovation until it
turns into a cookie cutter super your
origin story
you guys to feel this our origin story
begins with the dumb scooby-doo twist
and a supporting cast that's literally
forgettable but maybe don't leave your
team stranded on a spooky island next
time oh man boo who cares
baymax is BAE so enjoy another entry in
what might be a new Disney Animated
Renaissance that takes the cold
emotionless fields of science and
engineering and transforms them into a
heartwarming tale with the power of hugs
lots and lots of hugs
it's like spooning a warm marshmallow
going for a non-threatening huggable
kind of thing
let's hug last hug if I could have only
one superpower right now would be the
ability to crawl through this camera and
give you a big hug story Obamacare hero
is it me you're looking for a TJ Miller
type human Segway dreadlocks I love
April ooh nerd gag and spooky Legos the
in credit wins
does this symbol mean anything to you
guys we're getting another Hunger Games
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
hey spring junkies July 4th may be over
but the fireworks are just starting
because we just dropped 4 brand new
episodes of after credits for you to red
white and binge click the box to check
out our end credits scene for Superman
and head to screen junkies calm as he
scenes from Terminator 2 guardians of
the galaxy and more why because freedom
Jon Snow avenged the red wedding he is
the White Wolf the King in the north
winter is coming or you know nothing Jon
Snow
grab a mop there's gonna be guts on the
ceiling up down AAB left right a B up a
down right right left B up left a right
B left right a left up a down a right
left B start I like The Last Airbender
by M night Shyamalan there I read all
the stupid comments can I go home now